i want you to pick a goal and do not
even start with i want to lose five
pounds i want more money these are what
i call wishy
washy goals no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal so if you say well i
want more money that's my rug oh hang on
a minute
hey i've got ten dollars here there you
go you go well that's not my goal but
you said
i want more money and i learned this
when i used to work with women who were
infertile that come and they go you know
i just want to be pregnant i want to be
pregnant so bad
if i was just pregnant i go well
as i look at your notes you've been
pregnant six times i know i keep
miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great mum yeah
that's my goal
why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal
is to have a perfect baby how about this
my goal is to get lots of attention for
what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants explosive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal on whatever i'm going
to have my own company create my own
business invent something you can have a
relationship goal my relationship is
wonderful we grow
in loving and respecting each other and
you can have a health goal
but i want you to pick one only one not
three not five not in one goal it can be
career
it can be health
it can be love pick one goal
and then
i want you to decide why you want that
goal so much so the first thing is i
have a goal
i want to have my own business that's my
goal and now you're going to go to a
next page and write out why
do you want to have your own business so
much and the more reasoned you can write
out why the more likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many wise as you
can and remember
you can come back any time to this and
think oh i thought of another why and
another why so leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who
will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal
the more reasons you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you
achieving a who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie
in a bottle that says your wish is my
command and i want you to understand
that every thought you think
and every word you say is a blueprint
that your mind body and psyche must make
real so when you write out your goals
don't say i wish i could be rich
i long to be in a loving relationship
write it as if it's already happening i
am
a millionaire i am in a loving
relationship like well that doesn't make
sense it does make sense because your
mind only works in the present tense
when you say next year i'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is
and so you must write your goals in the
present tense i am i always i have i do
you must use words that make a picture i
want more money where you can find 10
cents or a dollar
but you have to say no i want more money
i am making a phenomenal amount of money
i am making a million dollars because i
monetize a gift i have or i make 10
million dollars a year because i
monetize the skill
then you have to make it detailed you
have to give your mind an image to go
towards what you want wants you
want to be happy build a life not just
the business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how the law of attraction really works
enjoy
rule number two broadcast positivity
with bruce lipton the science it says
there are two minds that are operating
at the same time one is called the
conscious mind one is called the
subconscious mind i say what's the
difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so uh the subconscious mind is
not thinking creating a subconscious
mind push the button
play the behavior so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say
oh i wish i had this and i desire that
and these are the things i want
and then you go out and start the day
and then guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science is recognized 95 of the day
because we are thinking 95 percent of
the day our behavior is now controlled
by the subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is
the conscious mind with your creativity
has your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging
and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have and
then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator
of your life and when people are in
mindfulness they manifest their wishes
their desires and their happiness so for
all of us it's sort of a wake-up call
you think you're running your life with
your wishes and desires it's an illusion
you're really running your life with
your programs acquired from other people
in our mind we start to realize that
we're concerned we're afraid we don't
have enough i'm not safe i'm not secure
and i say oh these thoughts i was
talking about the thoughts in your mind
go in and control your biology your
genetics your physiology and your health
and i go yes this is really true
i said well how can i tell you what your
thoughts are in a sense that can i read
your thoughts and i say yes you know i
could put wires on your head and it's
called
electroencephalograph and i could read
your brain activity and i go oh great i
can see this brain activity
i want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were
programmed to believe that our thoughts
are contained in our head that if i have
a thought it's just for me not for
anybody else it's inside and it's
working through me
and now i want to tell you about a new
technology it's not electro
encephalograph it's called magneto
encephalograph i say what's unique about
that i say read your brain i say yeah
but so does eeg i say yeah but eeg you
put the wires on the head and you get
the electrical activity conducted
through the skin from the brain and
that's what i'm reading and i said
what's different about emig
the probe
is out here
and i said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head
your thoughts are broadcast to the field
just like a radio broadcast
i say well what if i as an individual
have a thought that says
let's have peace in the world
and i broadcast out there in the street
and i say let's have peace and i look
around it's like
where's the peace i don't see the peace
and here's what the relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is amplified
each of us has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field i say your energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
i'll give you this most wonderful quote
i used it the other day in a lecture
from albert einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field
so definite definition the field is the
invisible energy right now you're in a
field there's cell phone broadcast
for
television
radio broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field
the quote
the field
is the sole
governing agency of the particle
particle is the material realm
so what was einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives and if
enough of us collectively have an energy
that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast a belief
we change the world
i just want you to recognize as much as
i wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if i want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced
that the war is going to benefit them so
that their broadcast say yes let's have
a war because i and my colleagues we're
all going to have a better result from
that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively or when we
collectively share
thoughts
and yoga
when you're in your postures when you're
in your process your mind is sharing a
thought not just in your head but all
around you
so the whole idea about this is we have
to recognize
we are collectively creating reality
with our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking
you get enough people to say peace there
will be peace instantly in this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to
give them the power to tell us what we
need
and assad fiji has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and i really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field
and that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore
what this world is looking for at this
moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough
it will end rule number three ground and
connect with mary kate
if nothing else understand this at least
and when it comes to manifesting there's
this false idea that something is
granted to you if you try hard enough or
follow enough steps or techniques or if
you meditate long enough it's like then
you're deserving and then something
outside of you grants it to you but no
that's not how manifesting works stop
waiting for something outside of you to
determine what you get to have and how
your life gets to be
that starts with you start deciding
start attracting you attract at the
level of your thoughts and opinions
so right now right this second
make the commitment to look at all of
the areas of your life that you don't
absolutely love and change the way you
see it change your opinions about it
change your thoughts about it change
your mind about it this is where the
reprogramming really begins
so to reprogram your brain to manifest
abundance with ease here is what you're
going to do in order to reprogram your
brain you first have to start with your
programming and the definition of
abundance means more than enough
so if you're looking at your programming
at what point in your life or growing up
were you taught that there wasn't enough
of something maybe not enough money or
not enough time not enough of anything
and examine where that you feel less
than abundant and see where it came from
see where it was formed so that you can
change your beliefs about it so after
you watch this video you are going to
either journal and if you don't like to
journal then meditate on where in your
life that you were made to feel that
more than enough wasn't available to you
or more than enough wasn't an option who
told you that what did you experience
where did you learn that because it's
not true that's just your belief your
opinion abundance is a state of mind
it's a very strong opinion that there
are unlimited resources available to you
at all times that more than enough is
always an option and it's always
available to you
and once you understand that on a deep
level
nothing can derail you i mean nothing
for example your phone or computer stops
working who cares you can buy another
there's more than enough available to
you your bank account's low more money
will show up in there because you make
more money than you could ever possibly
spend these are beliefs that you have to
start tapping into that those beliefs
right there are abundance and that is
powerful that will shape your reality so
once you do that and get clear on where
that programming came from where that
scarcity not enough not enough abundance
available to me comes from you are
actually going to form a new neural
pathway to abundance neural pathways are
formed in your brain so here's how
you're going to do it forming a new
neural pathway requires repetition and
commitment so you are going to do what i
call grounding into an affirmation we
had a whole month inside of create where
i explained this concept even deeper and
if you don't know what that is i'll
explain it a little bit later in this
video but grounding into an affirmation
means essentially anchoring to it so
deeply that it almost carries you
throughout your day so you are going to
ground into this affirmation and commit
to it daily
repeating it over and over and over and
over again
and when i say commit to it
i mean you have to say it and feel it
and believe it and connect to it don't
just say it over and over again without
any connection because that's not going
to do anything
now here is the affirmation that you're
going to use to reprogram your brain and
form this new neural pathway and the
affirmation is of course i can have what
i want more than enough is always
available to me
or
if you want to get more specific to a
certain thing that you're trying to
manifest or a certain area that you
don't feel really abundant you can use
something more specific something like i
have more money than i could ever
possibly spend or whatever specific
circumstance that you're manifesting
find what fits best for you but i
personally love the affirmation of
course i can have what i want more than
enough is always available to me because
i find this affirmation to be a very
powerful way to tap into a new level of
abundance in all areas of your life and
once you experience that level of
abundance there's no going back so
notice your programming change your mind
about it and commit to grounding into
this affirmation connecting to this
affirmation letting it carry you through
and i can promise you that when you
truly connect feel and embody this
affirmation you will feel a noticeable
shift and your reality will begin to
reflect it right back to you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four feel the fullness
of life with eckhart tolle now if you
want to
create something
that is not
an egoic
thing but is
something
you really realize from the depths of
your being that
something wants to be created through
you
whatever it may be
maybe you want to
you're writing a write a book
open a hairdressing salon
uh create a
[Music]
retreat center
or a conscious business
or whatever
you want to create
and you have the image the vision comes
to you
[Music]
or you may want to create a
it's not necessarily selfish a better
place to live a place that is externally
more peaceful
than where you are now or warmer
you may have a vision of what it is that
you want to achieve
and
then you focus on that vision
and the most powerful way to manifest
as you probably know
i don't
usually talk about that too much because
other things are more important if i
talk about the foundation for your life
but manifesting is a secondary thing
that
can be significant in your life
and to manifest
the most important secret to use that
word i'm not specifically referring to a
book called the secret but that's
the but
there's helpful things in there too
as long as you don't believe that
[Music]
certain things that you want to manifest
are going to make you happy
the
the power to manifest
is in
experiencing
the
fullness
of the present moment
the undifferentiated fullness what jesus
called
life in its fullness
[Music]
in one of the translations
i want you to have life in its fullness
he said
and that is not stuff is not referring
to things
life in its fullness is an inner state
of being
it is to experience to know to realize
the beingness within you the i am
with this consciousness itself
that is life that is the fullness of
life in the words of jesus
the fullness of life
is to to ex to realize that
so that
once you realize that and it is
consciousness
you you know yourself as consciousness
once you know
that then
[Music]
no future moment can possibly be better
but anything that can happen in the
future isn't adding on to
so if you bring together
if you have a vision in your mind of
what it is you want to achieve or create
or manifest
[Music]
and you bring this vision
into this sense of
still
fullness
[Music]
that you sense now
and you bring it together that is the
most powerful
creative tool the way that
it's usually expressed jesus expressed
it too he said when you pray for
something
uh believe that you already have it
that's but i think he probably used
actually slightly different words but
that's how it was written down
he said
he's
probably said feel that you already have
it
whatever it is that you want to have
that you think is going to be
you need to you need to feel already the
feeling that you know how do you do that
by feeling that which is beyond
the world of phenomena
out of which everything arises which is
consciousness
so when you know yourself as
consciousness
that's already the fulfillment
let's say
even
an insignificant thing
let's say you want to
have an
uh
a nice house let's just say
if i had a nice house in the out in
nature then i would be really happy
i want to have a nice a nice house or in
nature next to a little forest
and then there's a lake there
and i can walk to the lake
and then how would you feel
okay
i would feel
exactly the way i'm feeling now
i want to live in hawaii
and then i have a
decked out so i have a deck behind my
house with a very comfortable chair and
then i would sit in there every day and
contemplate the ocean
well good luck
how would you feel
what would you feel
i would feel the fullness of life
okay
and you can't feel it now
no why can't you feel it now
because i'm not sitting in this deck
chair
and i'm not looking at the ocean
and it's not
sunny that's why i can't feel the full
and i don't have a house behind me that
i say is mine
so i can't feel the fullness of life now
[Music]
okay then do you think you're going to
feel it when you finally sit in it
actually no if you can't feel it now you
can't feel it then
because you will be again dissatisfied
in your deck chair behind the house
because you will get very bored
and stunned by mosquitoes
and it's too hot anyway i should have
gotten a house higher up
because
down here by the beach it's just too hot
why didn't i get the house bit higher up
because there's a mountain just behind
me would be cooler
when you sell your house
get one higher up but in the nights are
too cold you can't sit outside anymore
[Laughter]
if you're not
if you cannot feel the fullness of life
on your bicycle
and enjoy that moment tremendously of
being on your bicycle
[Music]
you will not feel the fullness of life
when you're sitting in your
rolls-royce or bentley or ferrari test
test-serum test tester rosa
there's an overvaluing of things around
you
that i need
things to be in a certain way around me
to be happy and content
that doesn't mean that you cannot change
the environment around you you can take
steps towards changing it
because
you may have certain preferences
that's fine everybody has a preferences
the preference there's some spiritual
teachers who say
oh i don't know who i can't remember but
there are some who say
i have no preference
well
they live somewhere but not somewhere
else
so you must have a preference for being
there
unless somebody picks them up and puts
him somewhere
so you can you can have a preference for
living here rather than there
yes this country rather than that
country
but while you're not there
you can
be in touch with the fullness of life
within yourself now
and then it's much more likely that your
external surroundings will reflect your
state of consciousness rule number five
observe your thoughts with rhonda byrne
how do we break that negative thought
pattern right so
so you i mean the mind is like a
computer program so and and the fact
that it's on a negative loop is because
we programmed it on a negative loop but
but you know we could have been
influenced when we're children and
things like that so
um so
one of the things that the mind loves is
love's repetition i mean he loves it you
know if you really watch your thoughts
this is the same old thoughts over and
over again you know it's just kind of
dishing up the same old thing so it
loves repetition so the way you can
override a program is to put in the
opposite you know and when you start out
you know you feel like you're lying you
know you'll say something like you know
you might be really broke i was when i
was making the secret so
um
you might not have any money and you're
trying to instill you know wealth and
prosperity and riches and every time you
say it you feel a contraction in your
body because you know you don't have it
but you know truly because i did it
myself after a while you change it you
you really begin to change it and you
don't quite have that contraction
anymore and then you start to see money
coming in you know in in different ways
um and and
and or you can be given things that you
were going to buy and now you don't have
to buy it or so you begin to see you
start to see signs of land you know is
one of the great
one of the great new thought
thought um writers would say talk about
a sign of land so you start to see sign
of land
now that's what i did in the secret you
can do gratitude that will turn
everything around that will make you
feel good that will get you off the
negative right
but those negative thoughts are coming
from beliefs held in the subconscious
mind right that's where the beliefs stem
from for most of us they stem mostly
from our childhood
conditioning
yeah somebody's our parents said
something to us we just swallowed it
hook line and zinka
you know we're like right that's a
belief
and uh and so we take it in and and then
we have all these beliefs that that uh
and you can hear you know if you if
you're talking to somebody like if if
somebody says oh i believe
or because we say that all the time or
somebody says
i think
behind those two
behind those two statements are going to
be a belief
and so the really interesting thing
they're hard to spot because you believe
they're true
they seem real yeah so you don't think
yeah you don't think they're a belief
you think they're real you know and so
they can be hard to spot but if you
start to listen to yourself you know i
believe or i think or especially look at
the things that you have a really strong
opinion about
because where you have a really strong
opinion is a belief that's underneath
that
so
so one of the things that in the latest
book is that i show how to
um show how to dissolve those those
beliefs and
just really by some of the things that
i've just mentioned
and uh and and you can dissolve them and
you just feel free every time a belief
goes out you feel completely free
you know it's a it's amazing amazing
feeling
to you just feel as light as a feather
and actually you feel invincible rule
number six study the laws of life with
bob proctor have you ever spent any time
wondering how does everything happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
in fact in some places it does
but
i spend a lot of time thinking about
this
in fact at times it almost drives me
crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud bloom and leaves pop
out
and the leaves generally in the spring
are a very deep greeny brown they're not
a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're most
beautiful it is the most beautiful tree
and it's right outside in my studio
i'm sitting here in my desk and
the camera's around me but
out there is that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
every spring they're
greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring
they're always red in the fall and
greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder
why
the tide goes way out the tide comes way
back in
i spent some time in the navy in canada
and
i was down on the east coast for a while
and i was near the bay of fundy do you
know the bay of fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around prince george on the west
coast
you go onto a ship
and you might be walking up a plank just
right straight up and you go off the
ship sometimes you're going right down
that ship goes way up in here and it
comes way down very high very low tide
now some place the tide's not very big
they do have a tide but not too high not
too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know
just stayed at a certain length you
wouldn't have to cut it but it would
always look pretty
you know
do you think about this do you know that
everything in this universe happens in
an exact way
an exact way
not by chance
but in an exact way
when john kennedy
the president of the united states acted
as dr warner von braun
who was the
mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring him back
safely to earth
von braun answered him in five words the
will to do it that's it the will to do
it
he knew you didn't have to know how to
do it he knew you had to learn how to do
it but you didn't have to know
to make up your mind you were going to
do it now why did he say that because he
understands the laws
von braun one time said after years of
studying the spectacular mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of god and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise
that we don't even have any difficulty
building spaceship we send people to the
moon and we can time the landing with
the precision of a fraction of a second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone i see the laws as god's
modus operandi but i'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law when
you and i
get in harmony with the law now we do
that odds are pretty good we should
understand them but when we get in
harmony with the law then i'm going to
tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them i'm going to
you'll shock yourself with the good you
can do now i've been doing that for the
last 58 years i'm starting to get a
really a reasonable grip on them but i
don't understand them as well as i want
to or would like to
but i'm going to study a little more
today you know i get my
trusty book out here
i'll have to talk to you about this book
uh that'll be another talk
study the laws
find out what they write what they're
like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win and rule number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is visualize the obstacles with
john assaraf in the past i used to teach
and also do uh visualize my goals
whether my body health relationships
money charity whatever i used to
visualize the outcome and some of the
latest research now shows
um in addition to visualizing the
outcome visualize the obstacles
and in the past when we talk about this
law of attraction no don't visualize the
ops because you attract them to no no
your brain's way smarter than that
so if you have whether it's a belief
that's in your way
um a story that's holding you back a
circumstance uh references it you know
something that's holding you back from
achieving x
so take a look at whatever it is that
you already know is holding you back i
don't believe i'm worthy i don't believe
i'm smart enough don't mean that i'm
good enough don't believe me if i'm
skilled if i'm too young too old i'm i'm
to this or to that or not enough of this
not enough that so address that and say
okay here is an obstacle
i'm going to visualize that obstacle
being real and i'm going to visualize
just moving it aside and me moving
towards my goal the very act of
acknowledging that releases the neural
tension around if you do that over and
over and over again
what your brain starts to see is yes
there was a struggle
and so it's worthy of me creating this
neural pattern around this new effort
right because most of what we're doing
is you know we're being we're on
autopilot
we're just eeking through the day you
know on autopilot and so the brain loves
anything that makes it curious the brain
likes anything novel the brain likes a
challenge so earlier you're asking me
about you know one of the brain training
companies other than ours he said does
it work i said yeah it's a workout for
your brain
and if you can strengthen the neural
patterns of you seeing yourself with an
obstacle and overcoming it what do you
think that does to your self-confidence
and certainty fills it up big time
builds it up so if you'd if you actually
do the work
and develop those patterns in your brain
as you're doing the stuff you need to do
in the physical world you just
strengthen those neural patterns and
that's what becomes your habits
whenever i get an idea i have to do
something immediately trust your ideas
believe that they're amazing and and
manifest them into the world i love it
i'm not taking it from the approach of i
want this book to be a new york times
best seller and i'm sitting there
visualizing my book being a new york
times bestseller i'm not visualizing
myself being on brendon burchard's stage
in puerto rico to a couple thousand
people
that's not the process that i typically
go through although i'm open to that
maybe being a mistake i don't know
it's never really felt like
it's worth it i don't know i'm sitting
there i've done it many times sitting
there visualizing i've never really felt
like that made a difference
i'm open to being totally wrong
but
how i do apply it and
massively seen an impact is as soon as i
get an idea for something it's it's go
time trust that vision that came to you
trust that idea that's in your head and
do something immediately about it
when i thought about the idea of having
a house of building a custom home i then
went off and built the 5 000 square foot
custom home like inside of the year we
had the whole thing done
when i thought about silly things like i
thought about having a mannequin i was
watching green arrow on tv
and i loved how they all had their their
mannequins when they were in their their
lair or their realm they had their
outfits their costumes on a mannequin
and i thought i feel like i'm i'm the
green arrow i'm i got the deep hood look
i could be this is this is the believe
arrow right
uh i want a mannequin too and then
inside of a week i had my own mannequin
here and so it may seem crazy mainstay
wild but that's how i tend to operate
and i think it's amazing
right now i'm thinking about doing a 30
day challenge on my youtube channel my
main youtube channel where every day for
the next 30 days i have a series of
videos to help you build a better life
so like 30 days to a better life
and it's going to be some of our best
work and i thought of the idea and now
immediately we're doing it and so
trusting the ideas that come to me and
then immediately creating them and i
guess manifesting them into the world i
am a thousand percent all in on
the
sitting and visualizing
the thing that i want i have a struggle
with and i'm open to
making it better and and being changed
where i face the hardest time with this
is my health so
i broke my neck last year right i wore
this for for
60 days taking it off for 10 minutes a
day that was it and i had a concussion
and i had two spots in my neck that were
broken and i did some meditation with a
guy named michael edwards who
led me to this guided meditation and he
helped me and he was doing it with me in
person uh over over the phone sending me
videos and
first off was getting the concussion
away because i'd never had a concussion
before and the meditation i found really
helped the concussion the second part
was the visualization so i have a bone
in the back of my neck that broke off
so the big bone broke and it's healed
the little bone just kind of broke up
like the tip like imagine i guess a
fingernail kind of hanging loose right
and it broke off and the doctor said
it's not going to come back together and
and it's not worth going and doing
surgery on it because it's not a big
deal don't worry about it
and michael was convinced that i could
heal myself and i could make that bone
come back together and so every night
and every morning i would do it twice a
day meditating and visualizing the neck
coming back together and and you know
take some
you know hand sanitizer or not hand
sensitive take some lotion and and you
know put it on my neck and just as i'm
to get more tactical like as i'm doing
it the the bones connecting i talked to
john assaraf who was a another you know
legendary expert in his field and he's
he's fully convinced that he can come
back together through visualization
through meditation i haven't done it yet
i haven't i haven't i haven't cracked
the code on how to do it i wish i did we
did x-rays
uh 60 days later and it's still just as
disconnected it still just didn't move
a centimeter a millimeter closer
and
that was honestly a little bit
uh you know negative or low or defeating
and and my motivation to do it as
intensely has
has waned i haven't been doing it twice
a day every day
i still
want to believe that as possible and i
still
kind of believe that it's possible and
maybe that's not enough maybe that's the
problem
maybe the problem was i never believed
enough that it could happen and that's
why it didn't happen so i would i would
love for that to work i would love for
meditation to work i've meditated with
i don't know how many different people
so many different people i've never
really felt the benefit
[Music]
of having a meditation just feels
like i'm like i'm sitting down nothing
wrong with it just i don't feel extra
clarity or anything coming out of the
meditation so
i believe that has worked for other
people i believe that it can work for me
i haven't found the path to make it work
first of all every time we have a
thought we make a chemical and and if
you have
an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
turns out that the emotions that are
created from the thoughts are the
signaling mechanisms of the body
thoughts of the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects uh
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion a
stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person is
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
and we're thinking in the past right
and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i gotta see this person i gotta go to
that meeting i hate doing this and now
they get in their routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind so now the
person running through the same routine
every single day is on autopilot and
their body's now dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists
is the sweet spot of the generous
present moment that is when the body and
mind are free from those conditions so
along with those emotions that influence
the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency
you tap all the body's resources for
some threat whether it's real or
imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion and in a sense
they become addicted to the life they
don't even like and this is why change
is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours and the body's saying
you're out of schedule you normally at
eight in the morning you're getting
traffic and you're angry then at 11
o'clock you check your emails and you're
really judgmental and frustrated the
body's saying well you've been doing
this for the last 20 years you're just
going to stop today so now the body
which has been conditioned emotionally
to be the mind wants to return back to
its familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on this is a
good time to judge that come on this is
a good time to suffer it's your ex's
fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
then step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment
sit your body down like an animal body
is the animal tell it to stay i'm gonna
feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy so the person who has the strong
emotion to some circumstance in their
life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming overcoming overcoming until
we become somebody else we live in a
world that reinforces a scarcity
mentality and that mentality keeps us an
energy of lack it keeps us from
attracting the career path that we want
the abundance that we want and allowing
us to really live our purpose
there are six common blocks to abundance
and we all experience them in different
ways
the first block is a lack mentality and
when we have a belief system around lack
we create more lack in our life we all
have stories from our childhood how our
parents experienced abundance or how
they didn't and those stories start to
create a inner dialogue that gets us
into a vibration of feeling like we
don't have enough
and if we feel like we don't have enough
we do a lot of work to try to prove to
the world that we are enough
the second block is the belief system
that there's not enough to go around
we often overwork to try to get it all
we're constantly trying to get get get
because we don't believe that there is
enough it makes us feel like we have to
work so hard to get what we want and
that effort and that anxiety is really
really blocking the natural order which
is the flow abundance
the third block is the block of
comparison
we
literally just turn on our social media
and we're immediately into compare
compare compare
and comparing blocks are attracting
power because it focuses us on what we
don't have rather than feeling good and
feeling faith
the fourth block is the need to win in
the place of having fun because when
we're so focused on winning we lose
track of what it feels like to enjoy the
process and that winning can really get
in our way of allowing
the fifth block is the fear of rejection
when we fear rejection we don't take
action and in effect we create more lack
in our life because we're not actually
trying we're not actually putting out
our desires we're not actually taking
that leap towards what we want
but it's important to understand that
rejection can be protection
when we have some form of rejection show
up in our life it's the universe guiding
us to something better
and the final block is the fear of
judgment
you may be so terrified of being judged
that you don't take that action you
don't show up for your dreams you don't
even contemplate a world where you could
do the thing that you've been dreaming
of you're so afraid of judgment because
you think that other people won't
support you
but what's really important to recognize
is that if you're afraid of what other
people think and how they won't support
you it's typically a sign that you are
not supporting yourself now that you
know the six blocks to abundance i want
to give you my methods for clearing
those blocks so that you can allow
abundance to flow to you it's called the
universal abundance method
the first step of the universal
abundance method is to protect your
desires so you can stay in alignment
so if you have a really important desire
something that you care about something
that you want to manifest into your life
it's extremely valuable not to talk
about it with anyone who might resist it
step two is to focus on giving rather
than getting
the more we are in that service
mentality
the more positively the universe
responds to us this puts you into an
abundance mentality quickly because the
more you give the more you will receive
and step three is to want more for
others
it is an opportunity for us to see that
we all can succeed we all can have
abundance in our life and the second you
start to intend for others to have more
of what you want for yourself you start
to feel good you start to feel like
you're contributing you start to feel
like you're connecting and you're no
longer comparing or jealous and you're
no longer separating yourself from
others redirect your focus from what can
i get to how do i feel and really allow
that feeling of abundance to propel you
forward and create momentum and allow
the universe to bring to you all that
you desire if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything it's organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and
the fundamental life energies are
organized in one direction
once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in one direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance it's very
important
that our physical action
emotional action
mental action and energy actions are
controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the
planet so what should have been a boon
we are making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so
has also become a threat to our life
simply because
we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means
moving from
a compulsive state of activity to a
conscious state of activity
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the eight ways to manifest anything
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there close your eyes
for a moment will you please
and breathe with me just close your eyes
and if you will
put your thumb
to your middle finger